okay so i just saw a video of a dad
answering some riddles just pretty
simple riddles
and you got them all right so
i just figured out that you're a new dad
a great dad at that
what does a riddle have to do with a dad
why would a dad be better at riddles or
worse out riddles well i think it's just
kind of
synonymous with the dad joke idea
maybe you can also get some riddles
right
okay i don't i don't agree with this and
i don't want to do it but i'm
open to trying it because maybe i'll
have fun
[Music]
does africa have a fourth of july
every place has fourth of july
all july is everywhere july is
everywhere and it's the fourth day of
july
trying to trip me up all the stuff it's
a sweetheart the nature of a really
riddle is trying to trip someone up
that's what you think the riddler was
doing a batman
have to have coffee with them trying to
thwart him and
get money from like banks and steal
and rob
[Music]
what month has 28 days what month has 28
days
february all of them
oh you mean like also they have like
also more than 28 days
they all have 28 days
that's my birthday's on march 29th that
means it has over 28 days
so no march has more than 28 days
what planet are you on chris what planet
are you on
i don't get it i don't get it
i i don't get it it has 28 and it also
has two oh my god
dude it's riddle that's not riddlehead
riddlebrain that's not that one is that
doesn't count oh
how convenient it doesn't count that one
doesn't count how many days
how many how many months have
what month has 28 days february so so
okay so when i say how many days does
does may have oh it has 28 days and
three days also
three more days you say it has 31 days
or 30 whatever it is i don't even know
what may has
that one doesn't count i'm i'm i'm my
streak is good
are there any more you don't get to get
one wrong and then say it doesn't count
because you got it right there's no
wrong with that one
can i just ask one can i ask something
is there another one
are there more riddles yes okay so so
far i got them all
[Music]
name three consecutive days without
saying
monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday or saturday
yesterday today tomorrow yes
i get it i already get it i'm smart i i
dude i think outside the box dude
i don't think inside any boxes you put
any box
near me i don't ever go in there and
think i think i am outside the box
looking at the box
watching people think in that box and
i'm outside thinking why aren't they
doing it like me there's much more room
outside this box
yesterday today tomorrow
or i could have said tomorrow the day
after that and the day after that
or i could have said it in two weeks in
two weeks one day in two weeks
[Music]
there is a boat full of people yet
not a single person on the boat how is
that
there was a boat full of people
but not a single person on the boat
how is that how was that
there's a boat full of people but not a
single person on the boat
there's a boat full of people
but not a single oh they're all couples
yeah hell yeah dude i saw
the box outside that box dude that's not
they were swinging they're all swingers
this is not your boat
[Music]
well
there are 30 cows in a field
and 28 chickens look at all those
chickens
how many did it
you didn't the sentence is over yes
there are 30 cows in the field and 28
chickens
how many didn't
i'm like the meme of ben affleck house
ben affleck outside smoking
um there are 30 cows
in the field and 28
chickens look at all those chickens i
always think of that
and how many didn't
there are 30 cows in the field
and 28 chickens
dude that's the last time i let her do
that with my phone
hey let me record you and then we did
that so
i opened my mind up to do a new thing
that i would never want to do don't like
riddles
nailed them got them all got them all
right
honestly yeah i'll rate that since it
was quick
i'll rate it a 6 out of 10. that's
really not that good
that's really not that good only only
like in baseball a batting average six
out of ten would be amazing
but in any other sport it'd be pretty
damn bad but i
am basically really good at riddles and
i got all of them
and even the one that you said i didn't
get that was a wrong riddle that was not
a riddle that was not a good riddle
the answer is february it has 28 days
so i won that thanks for playing